I just really couldn't
be in La anymore I kind of bowed out of
that world Ireland Baldwin getting
candid about why she quit Hollywood I
can't handle it the model opens up about
making the big decision during a chat on
the high low podcast with Emily
radakowski on Tuesday so you're in
Portland now when did you decide to do
that I moved here almost going on like
three years ago I just really couldn't
be in La anymore it started to really
take a toll on me and especially over
covet it's just become kind of a really
a really just dark place La can be a
wonderful place but it's also a trap
and you know it's filled with a lot of
people who definitely don't have your
best interest Ireland grew up in the
spotlight thanks to her famous parents
actors Alec Baldwin and Kim Basinger
they're getting used to all the
attention
I mean there's always been kind of a
spotlight on our family and I think
we're used to that I think like yes I
was born into it I thought I was gonna
do a lot of things before settled and
decided to model because modeling was
sort of something
that just was so easy when I was young
the fashion industry is a tough one and
I had great experiences I had horrendous
experiences but unless I could really
kind of pick and choose and you know
kind of use that platform for good I
just didn't really want to be involved
in it anymore it's just kind of like
this cotton mouse game that you know I
just wasn't interested in and finding
that purpose it's something she echoed
to E.T in the past in modeling I think
it's definitely hard finding your place
and finding what your brand is because I
feel like everyone is a model now and
everyone is an actor and I'm like all
right if I'm gonna be in this business
and I'm gonna do what I'm doing I want
to have a voice for good I want to stand
for something and help people and you
know people aren't going to like me and
that's fine and I understand that and I
wouldn't honestly I would get I wouldn't
like me either if I was the daughter of
somebody that's just modeling
I woke up like this
iron Linda began her modeling career in
2013 and even tried a brief stint in
acting has there been any piece of
advice that your dad or your uncles have
kind of imparted on you guys as you
navigate this crazy crazy business I'd
say just to be your own person and kind
of find your Niche and find what it is
you love and just do it fall out you
know now Ireland says being an actor
well it's not her thing I
kind of tried my hand here and there
with certain projects and I can't act
for
it is not in my blood
of course she says that didn't stop
others from pressuring her to follow in
her family's footsteps I think people
don't realize from the other side of it
growing up in the whole netball baby
sphere of things is how many people you
have in your ear your whole life telling
you
that this is all you're meant to do like
ever you know like you're gonna be a
star and you're gonna do this and your
mom and your dad and it's in your blood
after hearing that for so long you kind
of are like I should try it with acting
in particular I was just like I hate
this like
[Music]
thank you